continuing our journey across the world
exploring strange terrifying and crazy
folklore we have been to sweden and more
recently north america now for today's
episode we won't have to travel far as
by very popular demand we will be taking
a look at some native american folklore
if the few native american legends i've
covered so far on the channel are
anything to go by then this should be a
very fun episode
before we go any further today's video
has been sponsored by babel the only
language learning platform and
application you'll need
for me learning the basics of different
languages definitely helps when
pronouncing legends and stories from
other countries i started using babble
on my computer but then switched over to
the app on my phone as it meant i could
use it on the go with babel you can
learn languages in all manner of ways
and it doesn't matter if you're a
beginner or an expert there are live
lessons taught by teachers pre-planned
lessons games videos and even podcasts i
personally like the 10 minute lessons as
i can fit multiple in throughout the day
and realistically it's probably time i
would have spent browsing on my phone
anyway babel also teaches you more than
just vocabulary you learn all sorts of
history culture and traditions
i chose spanish as the latest language i
would try not to butcher
hola
see i'm basically spanish now
all jokes aside if you'd like to start
learning a new language then use my link
in the description for 65 percent of
your subscription
in the forests of eastern canada and the
great lakes region the algonquin people
tell stories of a mythical creature a
terrifying spirit evil in nature
its hunger cannot be satiated and so it
searches for victims to possess
those who fall under its influence have
an uncontrollable desire to murder and
cannibalize other human beings the
creature in question is indeed the
wendigo
an enormous monster forged from ice that
grows bigger and bigger in line with its
appetite you'll know when one approaches
as even the slightest breeze becomes a
petrifying chill
the air is filled with a stench that can
only be compared to death itself because
that is what follows wherever the
wendigo goes
the wendigo represents greed
famine
starvation
the cold and corruption
its appearance at its core is still
somewhat human just amplified in the
worst ways
a dark
twisted and terrifying representation of
humanity
its vices and hardships
the wendigo is a creature we've already
covered so i'll leave a link in the
description for anyone who wants a more
detailed explanation
another creature we've discussed is the
skinwalker an individual often seen as a
witch of sorts who can disguise and
transform themselves into an animal
animals associated with skinwalkers
include coyotes
wolves bears
dogs and numerous others
there are several different types of
skim walkers discussed in navajo culture
but they are always seen in a negative
light
those in the community who are helpful
in both a spiritual and physical way
will often be referred to as medicine
men and women
these men and women embody everything
positive about navajo culture and
values part of becoming a healer
involves learning various practices
including a balance of magic that can be
seen as good and also evil the
skinwalkers can be seen as the polar
opposite they may once have been
medicine men and women but in this
process they were tempted by the evil
and nefarious arts
the responsibility of this power is too
much for some and the allure of the
twisted and dark ceremonies is too
strong they are corrupted and become
witches instead
where a medicine man or woman would use
their gifts and ancestral guidance for
good skinwalkers may hide amongst their
tribe in plain sight during the day
only to transform and perform these evil
acts under the cover of night
stories and legends relating to
skinwalkers are very important and so
they are not really discussed with those
considered outsiders
the process of becoming a skinwalker
therefore is virtually unknown
some theory suggests in exchange for
such power one would have to perform a
truly monstrous ceremony an irredeemable
act
taking the life of someone close to you
perhaps a family member
given the dark tone and severity of
these legends it's understandable why
they are not spoken of in much detail
horned serpents and dragons appear in
most cultures and native american
cultures are no exception
there are numerous names for these
creatures across the many tribes
the cherokee refer to this serpent as
the uktana a large underwater serpent
with shimmering scales that burn bright
horns and a crystal located in its
forehead
the scales and crystals were thought to
have magical properties and were used
for divination
the horns also had medicinal properties
which would make hunting these serpents
terrifying as it may seem a worthwhile
endeavor
it's said that a horned serpent that
resembles a stag will not harm humans
but its crystal seems to have a magnetic
power over other animals
the cherokee saw this glistening crystal
as the greatest prize
however it was also the greatest danger
those who encounter the serpent are
drawn in by how bright the crystal burns
rather than flee they are drawn towards
it and in turn their death
to make the hunt even more challenging
the majority of its scales are
impenetrable the only way to kill the
octana is by following the rings and
spots that run all along its body
the seventh spot from its head is where
its heart is located
and this is the only area vulnerable to
any kind of attack
there are some stories of these serpents
being driven away and destroyed by the
thunderbirds which segues us nicely into
our next creature
similar to the horned serpent the
thunderbird was thought to occupy the
great plains and the great lakes region
a large bird that could generate thunder
by simply flapping its wings hence the
name
often portrayed as a giant eagle they
sometimes also have control over the
rain and other elements of the weather
the conflict between the horned serpent
and the thunderbird relates back to an
algonquian story
the thunderbird reigned over the upper
world and the horned serpent reigned
over the underworld
when these creatures from the underworld
would attempt to invade the upper world
the thunderbird watching from above
would flap its wings and shoot thunder
down at the invading creatures
there are several stories that state the
thunderbirds were created to fight the
underworld spirits but also to punish
humans who broke the morals and codes
that governed their society although the
thunderbirds were seen as protectors and
you often do see them depicted on totem
poles they still served as a reminder of
the morals that were valued
the dear woman or dear lady is certainly
an archetype we see often in folklore a
succubus
siren or seductive type of monster
depending on the situation she can
appear in two different lights for men
who remain faithful and take care of
their families she is a spirit
associated with love and fertility
however those who harm women and
children encounter a very different
creature a vengeful monster who lures
and seduces these men to then murder
them for their misdeeds and sins
some believe that seeing the dear woman
at first is more of a warning a reminder
that some kind of personal change must
occur
if this warning is ignored the next time
you see her will be the last
for those wondering how the dear woman
punishes these men she hides behind a
bush or tree and calls out to them only
revealing her human side as these men
are unfaithful the call of a beautiful
woman is more than enough to grab their
attention by the time they are close
enough to realize she isn't entirely
human it's already too late
her hooves are used to trample and stamp
her victim to death
i'm sure there's a message there about
not taking advantage and treading all
over the people who care about you but
being punished by a dear woman who
literally treads all over you seems like
the perfect amount of irony
in cherokee folklore existed a figure
known as spearfinger a woman with
stone-like skin and an elongated
razor-sharp finger on her right hand
that she would use to slice open her
victims
she would walk the trails and rivers
surrounding the great smoky mountains in
tennessee and north carolina
it's said that you can hear spearfinger
humming her favorite song echoing
throughout the mountains and scaring
away any nearby wildlife
although nobody was safe she preferred
to target children transforming herself
into family members to deceive them
she could also take the form of a
helpless elderly woman those kind enough
to offer her assistance are left
regretting their decision
defeating spearfinger was near
impossible as her skin was made of stone
arrows and any other kind of sharper
weapon would merely bounce off her
her only known weakness was that her
heart was located in her right palm and
so she clutches it tight using her
elongated finger as protection
eventually the cherokee tribes came
together and devised a plan to finally
kill spearfinger
under advice from a medicine man they
dug a large pit and with green sapling
created a bushfire large enough to
attract her attention
she came to the village disguised as an
elderly woman asking for assistance the
hunters soon realized this was a
disguise and began to attack
the spears throne bounced and ricocheted
this only angered spearfinger as she ran
towards them however this was expected
and in chasing them she had fallen into
the pit
even with her trapped the cherokee had
no idea how to kill her
they noticed the birds who were once
terrified of spearfinger flew down to
offer assistance one bird began to sing
the sound it was making translated to
mean heart
the hunters took this to mean shoot her
in her chest and so they took the bird's
advice
the arrows and spears once again could
not penetrate spearfinger's skin and so
they turned to the bird and cut out its
tongue and raged it would lie to them
however the bird did not lie the hunters
were unaware that her heart was not
located in her chest another bird flew
down but this time landed on
spearfinger's right hand
the hunters listened again and began to
attack the hand that was always closed
so tightly
only now spearfinger began to panic
eventually one of the spears severed her
heart and she fell to the ground
the stone giant that plagued the lands
was gone
but the legend and stories of
spearfinger continued
and that brings today's episode to an
end let me know which of today's stories
were your favorite in the comments below
as always
i've been your host mythology and
fiction explained
you